hello my name is Anderson I am professor
in the federal arrest of return to
Brazil talk about the magazine which is
the largest military in Brazil and my
presentation is about batting statistics
and education the first thing to do is a
mechanic civilization because there are
a lot of data to be collected in Brazil
so let's start it now because it can be
a delayed in order to the time chapathis
a little bit speed up I don't know how
to is there anything wrong with the
internet
yeah yep Ilona is an age conference yeah
okay okay
okay could you please rise the sound
that's okay all right
slowly things and importing data and
cleaning tables and so on and then few
seconds we are ready to go importing
files this is the mega Senna file and
cleaning and updated Korres because in
the last 20 years we have a lot of
inflation and currents must be updated
every time you run this you have the
most updated values okay just a second
we're going convert into dollars because
Rios there's no matrix make sense for us
and now we are ready let's go well what
is the Brazilian magazine it's only the
most important lottery in Brazil is
managed by the bank Brazilian bank is a
cash economic of federal and the only
cash economica federal which is the bank
could manage lotteries in Brazil and
they manage a lot of lotteries 9 it's a
tall magazine is the most important and
things you need to know before playing
well how to bet how to win
well the lottery has 60 numbers and you
can you can plays at least six numbers
and at maximum 15 numbers if you hit
four of them you win the Quadra if you
hit five numbers is Akina
and if you hit six is the center which
is the jackpot and the cost of a bet
with six numbers is what just one dollar
just like here in the United States and
if you increase the numbers you can bet
of course the price will be spinelli
higher the maximum you can bet is
fifteen numbers which costs in dollars
five thousand dollars and a half the
chances of winning is for a bet with six
numbers 150 million it seems to be
extremely low chance but here in the
mind state things are harder because
Mega Million Mega Millions a lottery of
nine states to win the jackpot the
chances is the one in 258 Millions
five times five times more difficult to
win than in Brazil and the Powerball is
this too hard because it's one in two
hundred ninety million chance okay so
it's six times harder than mega-santa
this is a typical lottery house in
Brazil and the play sleep in Brazil is
pretty much the same off in the United
States it's very close to them and you
just choose the numbers mark here and
pay if you want the jackpot alone if you
are planning to go to Brazil don't miss
the chance of betting on the magazine
because you can be a millionaire also as
long as you are as you can be here of
course the money is not this I'm sorry
is this this one I prefer that one but
embrace
you get bills okay
few statistics about the mega sauna
first one is the frequency of the
numbers drawn here are the most drawn
numbers number five is the champion
it has drawn has been around 250 28
times and the least one is number 26 162
people don't like people in Brazil don't
like to choose number 26 55 and so on
because they are least drowned and then
for many people
this is not a good idea to do though
many people only works with these
numbers is well where did the magazine
winners come from
of course from Brazil but in terms of
states here is a frequency of Senna
winners per state of course some Paulo
as the the the most of the sign of
illness comes from sample and 190 people
won the magazine in San Paulo second one
is miniaturize and Rio de Janeiro and so
on there are some states that for
example a Curie is an off state there's
only one people who own the magazine
[ __ ] i'ma also in North Region one and
Tocantins
which is a new state only 15 years I
think
Tocantins has been created but there is
a state that no one no one guy ever won
the magazine is called a mapa and
comparing these two plots this is the
population distribution you can call it
we can be sure that the amount of
winners of Santa is very correlated with
the population distribution also not the
the amount of money that population have
he have have have there ever been two
equal results in the magazine ad Ross
well we are now in the nineteen nineteen
seventy nine draw and so far there is no
no coincidence between two different
drawers but in terms of five matching
not six but five matches there have been
eleven and curiosity here is that in row
number three or nine these numbers match
five numbers of the subsequent that the
follow draw 309 in truth if five numbers
were the same this is impressive
here we formats has more lot of examples
here we are let's make a simulation of
the magazine and this is a simulator and
I hope you can see what is there I'm not
sure I need to take this this is a let's
see
yes can you see it barely but but here
it is not very important what is there
because what what is what does what is
matters is here look at this the first
coil control is the amount of money you
are about to lose here you can start
with $100 thousand dollars ten thousand
until 1 billion dollars why 1 billion
dollars who has 1 billion dollars crazy
billionaire of course and the number of
bets you can do at time can be 110 and
201 million why I took so I put so
larger numbers because in the simulation
that's the good thing to do crazy things
isn't it and the quantity of numbers per
bed which could be 6 or 215 you can
choose it and here's the Colin is a
Brazilian thing called Timo Xenia the
machine means that you can pay now and
your bed Valis for two or three weeks
you don't need to go back to the lottery
house and the waiting at home so with
the minimum with the minimum criteria
here you just run it and see that you
want nothing like here price earn it
nothing but you lose one dollar and ten
cents okay you run again you were
nothing of course
why you don't gain anything because
first the the the chances is absolutely
against you and here I added a
think that could be very educated in
terms of education is a very powerful
argument a people who has this criteria
just one five six numbers one by eight
and so on to win the Sena he in average
it could be necessary for four hundred
and eight thousand years four hundred
and eight thousand years making a bet
one one at a time one at a time of
minimum requirement and two in the kena
is one thousand years only and the
Quadra twenty two years only to her to
talk to win a quarter of course you can
improve it spending more money for
example let's suppose that I'm going to
start with ten thousand dollars which is
the money that I can have you can have
ten thousand dollars well the number of
beds ten at a time for example ten ten
forms and of course I must increase the
numbers but not too much because here is
the amount of money that you must pay
for the bed and to see and take a look
of the years necessarily to to buy
something to won something
here's a two months three years and two
hundred twenty eight years so let's run
again and see if you if you want
anything nothing and nothing and nothing
and nothing and nothing nothing so you
are spending $2,000 every every time I
run this simulation if you really want
to want something
you need to play 15 and increase a
little bit the number of beds for
example thousand at the time
note that the here your chances are very
good 27 in one not one two in 27 but
it's the opposite yeah so the number
system will start here yes this time I
want one kena 15 quadrants because there
are some tricks in the ended in the
mechanism of the magazine in fact you
won 1050 quarter's because when you bet
too much numbers you can make a
combinations inside and it to generates
more quadrants than more Keenan's and so
on now you won 208 $9,000
but you'd in depth off a five million
that's no good and and so on but the
very good thing in this simulation is
that you can play the part of crazy
billionaire let's imagine that Mark
Zuckerberg or Bill Gates also one of the
wake up the mornings of Auburn 1 billion
dollars yes I never did it so I'll do it
today
and then I put I start with 1 billion
dollars let us clear everything before
and ok I want to make 100 bets at a time
because I have so much money why yes 50
numbers nothing more and nothing less
than this oh no this is 500 million
dollars that's half of the what I have
so I decreased a little bit
fifty-five minutes okay and then that's
run Wow
I I won that one Sena and three hundred
334 kookiness into 22,000 quadrants
which gave me 26 million dollars yeah
but your expense was 55 yes let's try
again
maybe the luck is with me okay how is
you got had an amount of 41 million
dollars but lose 110 there's no way to
win this thing if you are a compulsive
gambler yes that's right
gambler there's no way no you are the
best thing is sometimes you dream with
some numbers and go to the low-tech and
buy and win everything just one but this
is very very difficult to Churchill to
occur well going back to our
presentation let me see where is it yep
we can go to the last part of the
session which is tips from the experts
chips from the experts I before
preparing this simulation I never fall
about there are some guys there are
experts in teaching people how to win
the magazine people say oh if you know
how to win why don't you win they said
yes I did it 50 times now I want to
teach you for you to be a millionaire
also so here are the chips
tip number one prefer to bet more
numbers on the same play list than
in several simple baths I commend this
this is the default here the seven
numbers and here's seven play leads with
six numbers each well in this case they
are absolutely equivalent you want
nothing more nothing less
in terms of chances but of course if you
prepare that six playlists this would be
better if you play eight playlists this
will be better so there's no prefer to
bet more numbers on the same present
it's not because there are more numbers
that your chances will be higher so it
depends tip number two avoid choosing
consecutive numbers like four fives
only the crazy guy chose number and
consecutive but but it is as how can I
say the chances that you have that this
result comes out is the same of any
water one of course it's more is more
probable that the number will be
difference because there is a kind of
second law of thermodynamics it's almost
like entropy as more diverse as more
than the numbers is higher tip number
three try to balance the choice between
odd and even numbers this is the
Thurston because in fact if you compute
all the numbers that has been wrong in
the last 2,000 drawers of magazine the
numbers are almost the same but not in
the particular
result because it can be sometimes in
most of them odds are the other times
even and so on but not the results in
particular will be even inaud equal
parts tip number four divide the card
into four quad this is more relevant
interesting divide the card in four
quadrants and distribute your numbers
between them it's just like this here
this numbers has been drawn right now
I don't know why's worth four here let
me do it again
here look this is chosen by chance look
at this this quadrant here is there's no
one in here
just one let's do it again you can do
that very many times here and oh he is
okay distributed but here the two
quadrants there's no one so this rule is
useless
for many purpose tip number five do not
play on numbers that are on the same
vertical line oh my gosh here is I'm
sorry let me comment this it's difficult
to find the guy that would make choose
these numbers is very difficult I never
saw well in general they are spread
around this table and people expect the
results in this way tip number six do
not play on numbers there are very
strong oh that's that that's the table
that I changed a little bit
here are the
the plot of the numbers drawn the
frequency here are the number five I
don't think you can read it but the
twenty two hundred twenty times twenty
twenty eight and here is a twenty six
then the is distributed the number that
you are barely draw the numbers in
twenty six and there isn't one that
fifty five and so on
do not use that numbers in your bed
because you you lose for good chip
number seven never play result that has
a red come out because that never
happened yes it never happened but it's
about to happen because there are eleven
times that five numbers have mattered in
two different drawers and chip number
eight and the last one never bet on mega
Cena if you Hornung amoeba the kasama
far no one has won the magazine ever if
you go there and bet the magazine you
don't you don't want anything
thank you very much
[Applause]